good morning and welcome
my name is will gray runcal and i'm an
organizer of the symposium along with my
friend and colleague brock wester
from the johns hopkins university
applied physics laboratory
i want to introduce our topic today
entitled toward petascale and exoscale
connectomics
and with the advance of technology and
collaboration between
engineers and neuroscientists it's now
possible
to estimate networks of the brain at the
single synapse resolution
and so we're excited today to bring
together speakers to present recent
research breakthroughs and their
perspectives on the field
as well as related analyses that may
inspire future
research so collectively in the field of
connectomics
we work to image brain tissue and
estimate brain networks to answer
hypotheses about the brain's structure
and function
converting the raw uh biological tissue
into a format that can be more easily
analyzed by neuroscientists computers
and
mathematical techniques even in the
early days of neuroscience of course we
were able to capture information about
individual neurons
and more recent techniques technology
advances
have allowed us to look at the brain
through many different lenses and
technologies
however microscale circuits are still
not as well understood
and require advances in scalability
scientific understanding and community
and community engagement to interrogate
the brain we have many different options
ranging from magnetic resonance imaging
on the left where a cubic millimeter is
represented by a single byte
of information to the electron
microscopy data we focus on here
where each pixel is a few hundred cubic
nanometers and a cubic millimeter is two
petabytes
depending on the approach taken we can
then make brain graphs at different
resolutions
ranging from putative connections
between brain regions to detailed
synaptic level connections between
individual neurons
we think this works really important
because understanding these
microcircuits is a missing link to
understanding many neurological diseases
and informing diagnosis prognosis and
treatment we think these models will
have a great impact on diseases and
conditions such as traumatic brain
injury autism and parkinson's disease
also this field may be a key enabler for
replicating brain function and
understanding and validating theories of
neural computation and understanding the
brain
here's an outline of some of the steps
commonly taken in connectomics discovery
our speakers will touch on advances
ideas challenges and solutions in many
of these areas
from thoughtful experimental design
imaging data collection and storage
segmentation and meshing proofreading
and analysis
it's an exciting time to be in
connectomex where we're really at this
inflection point
in technology where many of the
classical challenges
and scalability and data generation and
analysis
now are achievable through
state-of-the-art techniques
our labs focused on solutions in
scalable storage
evaluating the quality of these
large-scale circuit reconstructions as
they're developed
mining that information for uh motifs
for
for computational primitives and small
networks
and then applying what we've learned
there to novel computational models
and i think you'll hear from many many
labs here and around this this meeting
um for for others who are doing doing
similar work it's it's a really exciting
time and
and there's there's much still to do
the field of connectomics is rapidly
accelerating
and as data sets continue to grow in
size we are able to leverage
technology to target much larger
questions
in just a few years we've progressed
from a brute force reconstruction of a c
elegans worm
to contemporary efforts to reconstruct a
cubic millimeter of cortex or a
drosophila brain
networks of an entire mouse and
large-scale comparative network
questions are now within reach we're
excited to share this progress
and some of the emerging research that
will catalyze the future of this field
here today we've gathered emerging and
established leaders in the field of
connectomics and are excited to talk
with you today
in this new and innovative virtual
format
and i'll leave you with a quote from the
founder of neuroscience santiago ramone
kahal who says that
the brain's micro circuits are
impenetrable jungles where many
investigators have lost themselves
and i think it's a really exciting time
like i mentioned where we're uniquely
poised to help understand the structural
and function
of the brain and so thanks to everyone
who made the symposium possible for all
of our speakers
and first up is jeff lichtman from
harvard university
connectomics began uh with the
work of sidney brenner a molecular
biologist and his colleagues john white
southgate thompson who
published after 10 years of work the
structure
of the nervous system of cll
40 page paper and itemized
the connections of every one of those
300 cells
that's the past of this field
uh if we fast forward uh 40 years
uh to now uh the same
kind of reconstructions can be done so
much quicker here's a paper
that was just put in bioarchive but it
is eight
connectomes including two adult connect
tones of c
elegans all done in a 15
page paper with the wiring diagram of
every cell and instead of requiring 15
300 pages it's 15 pages because all the
data is now
online if this is the present what is
the future
and what about instead of the mind of
the worm what about the mind
of a mouse could one do an entire mouse
let's
talk about this just for a second a
mouse is much bigger than the 300
neurons or so
in the elegance that worked you have
about 100 million neurons
100 billion synapses and the volume
is exceptionally large it's 500
cubic millimeters that would be
equivalent to a box that's approximately
eight by eight by eight
cubic millimeters and that's worth
saying because the state of the art
right now
is one cubic millimeter so this would be
a 500 fold increase
uh from where we are right now not only
is it a large volume that would have to
be image but it would be a
very large data set depending on the
voxel size
which would be somewhere between 500
cubic nanometers
to maybe a thousand cubic nanometers per
voxel this data set would be somewhere
between
500 000 and a million terabytes a
million terabytes
is an exabyte and that would be a
tremendous
uh challenge obviously to give you a
sense of why the mouse is sort of an
attractive animal to imagine doing a
complete mammalian connectome on
in a logarithmic way it is sort of
halfway between
the most uh completely studied
nervous system by connectomix uh which
is the fly brain
which has about a hundred thousand cells
so you multiply that by a thousand you
get
uh to the number of cells in a mouse
brain a hundred million
and a hundred million is a thousand fold
smaller than the number of cells in the
human brain which is a hundred billion
so you'd need about an exabyte of
storage um
no one wants to do this for multiple
generations it would be nice to be able
to complete this in
even half a decade at least the image
acquisition part and that is
possible if one parallelizes the imaging
using machines like multi-beam scanning
electron microscopes or other
fast methods and having 20 or 30
machines
it would be expensive just the cost of
buying
all those microscopes would be 100
million dollars
so you would have to multiply that
number by several uh
but maybe a small number of integers uh
to get
uh to the cost of the whole project
so this won't be an easy project uh if
it goes through
at all uh there are technical challenges
that have not yet been solved
and i would like to just list them very
quickly one is
metallizing a whole mouse brain getting
osmium through a whole brain
is going to require materials scientists
and organometallic chemist
uh thinking a little bit more seriously
about how
one can get a metal that is highly
reactive osmium tetroxide is highly
reactive
all the way through a brain secondly you
have to
section an image something that is much
bigger
than the volumes that have been done so
far this will probably require
physicists and mechanical engineers to
be thinking about the most efficient
ways of doing that
um one thing that has to happen is it
has to be very robust
uh the sectioning uh and imaging can't
lose
anything if you even lost 200 nanometers
somewhere in the middle of
the volume uh many many processes would
be
similarly the throughput has to be very
high i estimate maybe
in the range of about a thousand
terabytes per day
in order to finish a project like this
in half a decade
and finally uh you'd have to deal with
the scaling up of this huge number of
computational steps that are
have made connectomics work so well and
computer scientists and especially
those interested in deep learning and
artificial intelligence will have to be
playing a role
all of stitching and alignment has to be
done between sections by
computer scientists segmentation has
become
really quite powerful but doing it at
the scale
uh is just a new challenge and
uh one would have to build analysis and
rendering tools to deal with an exabyte
of data and finally there has to be a
way that this data can be easily shared
with as many people who want to look at
it as possible
none of these things are trivial
to do so uh
in conclusion i'd just like to ask
ask the question that maybe some people
are wondering about is
why why might we want to do this
and i'll just give you a quick bunch of
things a path towards unbiased
catalog of all the cells and synaptic
connections
of the whole brain with broadly
subserved mammalian neuroscience
a path for bridging the divide between
non-invasive
mesoscale imaging technologies like
functional magnetic resonance imaging
and ground truth microstructure how do
the synaptic connections relate to the
projections
and seeing that in the same animal will
be tremendously valuable
this will also be a path perhaps for
learning something about the structure
of long-term memory mammals
have a lot of behavioral repertoires
that come about to experience
that are stored stably for the life of
the animal including human beings
what is the structural basis of that
this will also be a path towards
describing the neuropathology
of brain disorders some brain disorders
almost certainly will be conectopathies
pathologies of connections uh animal
models
of disease will be possible once one
builds this infrastructure will be
possible to look at diseased animals
which will also be for computer science
a path towards designing
non-biological thinking systems that
have more properties that are similar to
those of
uh actual thinking animals for example
uh many machines can play chess or do
other board games
uh but or drive a car but they can't do
many things a blueprint for general
intelligence
is found in the wiring diagram of the
mouse
also we do a lot of few shot
learning as human beings and other
animals do the same thing we don't need
thousands and thousands of examples like
our machine learning
training data sets but we have to learn
better how
that is done and finally
it would take megawatts of power to
build a computer as powerful as a
mouse's brain
so we would learn something i think
about how energy efficient computing
works uh in our view a project like this
uh could likely be a turning point in
the human pursuit of understanding
uh what makes mammals and especially us
the unique animals
that we are thank you very much the next
person talking
is alyssa wilson princeton university
hi everyone my name is alyssa wilson and
i'm a postdoctoral fellow at the
princeton neuroscience institute in
sebastian sung's lab
and today i'd like to talk to you all
about some insights that we hope to get
from serial section electron microscopy
or em
of mouse brain in particular as we scale
this technique up to larger image
volumes
that's somewhat separate from the
primary goal of this technique that we
often put forth which is
identifying neural circuits and what i'd
like to talk about specifically is
structural correlates of synaptic
plasticity that we can use to learn
mechanisms of neuronal rewiring
and so we can get a better sense of what
i mean by that i'd like to just start by
reminding us
all what electron microscopy reveals in
biological tissue
the mode of contrast is metal stain that
targets lipids and some proteins and so
in an electron micrograph what we see
is all membrane bound objects as well as
some of those proteins
and if we look at an electron microscopy
image this is an adult mouse in the
visual cortex area v1
you can see that it's very densely
packed and the membrane-bound objects
involve parts of cells as well as pieces
of neurite
neurites i messed this up if we look at
so if we look at an example of an em
image this is mouse visual cortex v1
layer two three you can see that the
image is very packed with membrane-bound
objects and this includes cells and
pieces of cells
that we call neurites as well as some
intracellular organelles
like this mitochondrion and an
endoplasmic reticulum that i've shown in
red and blue respectively
and if we scale this technique up to
take series
of images of a piece of tissue we then
get a very powerful set of data
which is the 3d context for all of this
that allows us to make sense of it
so if we look at the data set that that
image came from this is the proof
of principle data set from the ir for
microns contract and it was acquired by
the allen institute for brain science
you can see that we have quite a few
large
portions of cells contained within this
image volume
including the cell here which is a
neuron and it has axons and dendrites
visible and the morphology allows us
also
to assign cell types this is a pyramidal
neuron
from layer 2 3 and because we can see
the organelles inside
of all of these cells we can also
determine what synapses are based on
features like synaptic vesicles
and post-synaptic density and so all of
that allows us to see the synaptic
connectivity between cells contained in
this volume
like the example i'm showing here of a
basket cell neuron in blue
and a pyramidal neuron in red and we've
been able to detect
using a neural network all of the is
formed by
that pyramidal neuron onto the basket
cell so with high throughput electron
microscopy we can start to answer the
following questions
first the question that often we ask
which is how are neurons synaptically
connected to each other
but also we can ask how are
intracellular structures like organelles
and protein structures related to neural
circuitry
specifically we can ask how do these
things vary in relation to synaptic
strength
and from that information we can move
forward and start to ask
what role might these things have in
synaptic classicity or developmental
rewiring
and how can we get that information
given the fact that em
gives us a static snapshot of a piece of
brain tissue
well if we look at an adult that's been
through developmental
rewiring we can see by measuring
the structural correlates of synapse and
organelle function
which synapses are strong and what the
differences and organelle
features might mean relative to that
strength
so to give a concrete example of what i
mean
by that statement i want to share some
preliminary work i've done
on this em volume on a particular
organelle that many people are familiar
with which is mitochondria
mitochondria are responsible for
generating atp in cells which is an
energy source that's necessary for many
cell functions
and also they have another function
which is to remove calcium ions from
their external environment
and they do this through membrane-based
uptake and importantly that means that
the size of a mitochondrion
is proportional to how effectively it
can remove calcium ions
this is in particular important for
neurons where the calcium ion
concentration is tightly controlled
and small changes make big differences
in
synaptic firing and other activity
related processes
and recently it's been found that at
synapses mitochondria actually halt
due to elevated calcium iron
concentration and while they're at those
synapses
they produce energy that is required in
order to maintain synaptic proteins
and also they affect the amount of
calcium ion available for synaptic
firing
so this information already tells us
that mitochondria might be important for
determining synaptic strength or
affecting it
moreover a few years ago people found
that mitochondria are modile during
development when often synapses are
adjusted in terms of strength based on
activity dependent experience
but they become stationary by adulthood
so all of this information taken
together leads us to ask the question
is there a relationship between
mitochondria and the synapse strengths
that are established during development
and so since in our proof of principle
volume we had a young
adult mouth brain tissue we decided to
analyze the mitochondria in that tissue
to start and try
and get at this question and so using a
neural network
that was aimed to detect mitochondria
it's similar to the network we use to
detect our synapses
we were able to generate segmentations
of the mitochondria
in this image volume with a relatively
high precision and recall
and overlapping those mitochondria with
our segments of the cells themselves
in this volume we were able to get a
data set in which
every segmented cell like this pyramidal
neuron
shown has mitochondria associated with
it that we can then study so if we zoom
in
on the cell body of this neuron you can
see
every different color is a different
mitochondria and this gives us a lot of
information about
where the mitochondria are how they're
shaped and what their surface area and
size might be
and that tells us about how well they
can for instance
remove calcium from their external
environment and give us a lot more
information about what might be going on
in the cell
so in this data set we looked at
excitatory synapses and the mitochondria
near those synapses
and by isolating the excitatory synapses
between pyramidal cells in the volume we
found about 5000 mitochondria within
about 5 microns of synapses and there
were about 1900
synapses that are formed between the 334
pyramidal neurons with some of contained
in this image volume
and just looking at these populations of
mitochondria has already
given us some interesting information
and i'll share with you some of those
preliminary results now
so looking at presynaptic mitochondria
we found that
only about 60 percent of the synapses
from excitatory pyramidal neurons onto
other parameter neurons have policeman
active mitochondria nearby
and if we assess one structural
correlate of synaptic strength
that is the dendritic spine volume
larger spine volumes correspond
to supposed stronger synaptic strengths
and we compare for synapses that do and
don't have presynaptic mitochondria
we find an interesting result in blue in
this graph
you see a histogram of spine volumes for
synapses that do have nearby presynaptic
mitochondria
and in orange you see the distribution
of spine volumes for those that
don't have presynaptic mitochondria and
we find that
if the synapse has a large spine volume
it likely has
a nearby presynaptic mitochondrion
and so this starts to suggest a
biological
insight which is that presynaptic
mitochondria may have a role in
permitting strong
synapses between excitatory neurons in
the visual cortex
if we look at the postsynaptic
mitochondria in this population we're
studying we see another interesting
result so almost
all synapses have postsynaptic
mitochondria within five microns of the
synax
so if we just look at that proxy for
synaptic strength
dendritic spine volume again and we look
at the size of those post-synaptic
mitochondria
for each of these synapses as a function
of spine volume
we see that small spine volumes have
exceptionally long postsynaptic
mitochondria in some case
so here's the data for that on each data
point here is a synapse
in our data set and the x-axis is the
spine volume of that synapse
and the y-axis is the average
mitochondrial length
and we see that the smallest spine
volumes have very long
mitochondrial lengths in their
postsynaptic mitochondria
furthermore earlier this year people in
our lab posted some work on bioarchives
that assessed the spine volumes in this
exact data set and we found that
spine volumes the distribution is shown
in black and it's modeled in red
they're well described by a sum of
gaussians
and we posit that those two gaussians
represent two states
the gaussian distribution on the left
represents potentially a weakened state
where spines have smaller volumes and
the gaussian on the right represents a
potentially
strengthened state of synapse strength
where the spines have slightly larger
volumes
and the natural split between those two
potential states
occurs at about .09 microns cubed
and so if we look at that particular
spine volume on our data with
mitochondria we find
that it's to a first order of
approximation
a good split between spines that are
very small
and have very long mitochondria and
those that are bigger and less likely to
have very long mitochondria
post-synaptically
so this tells us that mitochondria
may have a role in determining spine
strength postsynaptically as well
a suggestion is that excessive presence
of postsynaptic mitochondria might be
involved in synaptic
depression or down scaling and i'm happy
to talk more offline about that if
people are interested in
our class on it but these two examples
give us a picture
to summarize of what we have to gain by
looking at organelles in these volumes
in the future
visualization of organelles within
neural circuits can lead to really
important insights potentially about
circuit development or learning based
changes that occur
in brain tissue and so with that it
follows that organelle segmentation and
analysis will also be a valuable part
scale up in 3d em connectomics as we go
forward
with that i'd like to thank the people
at the sum lab at princeton
with that i'd like to thank all the
people at the sun lab at princeton
university as well as those in the allen
institute for brain science and baylor
college of medicine who worked really
hard to put this data set together and
i'd also like to acknowledge our funding
sources at iarpa
and the national institutes of mental
health thank you for
your attention and now i'd like to
introduce the next speaker who is luis
rodriguez
hello everyone my name is luis rodriguez
and i'm a member of the johns hopkins
university applied physics lab
here i'll briefly discuss some of the
questions and answers that the community
will have to consider when addressing
storage challenges
and ensuring data democratization at the
petabyte
and exabyte scale from our understanding
of the 300 neuron
302 neurons in the c elegans which
amount to about one terabyte of data
to the billions that make up the human
brain amounting to roughly 1.3
zettabytes
our community will face increasingly
larger challenges we're aware of a
number of fundamental challenges now
but there are unknowns that will only
emerge as we move forward
larger data skills this includes
collecting uploading and sharing data
so let's start there as researchers in
the community produce data of different
modalities and organisms we need to
think about where to store it to
facilitate the sharing and access
of the data and results as the rate of
data generation increases
more bottlenecks will emerge take for
example a carl zeiss multi-stem
microscope which can produce about 1.5
terabytes per hour
at that incredible rate we would still
need more than a month to finish
imaging an entire brain so even faster
processes are still
needed and our storage infrastructure
needs to be able to keep up with those
speeds
given challenges associated with
standing up and maintaining the required
physical storage
cloud and serviceless approaches provide
an attractive
option so fortunately there are a number
of current data approaches in the
community that support different
workflows tools and scientific pursuits
each of them having their various
strengths like the needless divide which
allows for versioning
bossdb which provides authentication and
serverless computing
and cloud volume which has a built-in
meshing infrastructure
i'm actually lucky to be a member of the
apl brain team
building bossdb as a part of the brain
initiative nih data archives program
so the inspiration behind the block
object storage service
database or bossdb is to provide a
platform for users to upload and store
volumetric data
at scale the bossdb offers a number of
services
to enable scientific workflows and
discovery
so scientists can upload data using our
injust client which leverages
a plug-in infrastructure to broaden the
scope of data formats and support ingest
of data sets over a petabyte in size
and we also have developed intern a
python sdk that provides
data access to support scientific
workflows intern allows us to create and
get data cutouts from the boss
using the bossdb api similarly it allows
us to access data from divide and cloud
volume
this synergy between data
infrastructures allows us to have the
best of all worlds making it seamless
for us to share data across platforms
and allowing us to use unique data
services
for example we could grab an object cut
out from the boss db
update and version it using divot's
versioning api and then generate a mesh
using cloud volume
all while caching the data locally with
an emboss first instance
like with other platforms to visualize
boss db's volumetric raw and
annotation and mesh data we can use open
source tools like neural answer
and to browse publicly available data
sets on the box we maintain a website
bossdb.org and as we develop boss db
and handle petabyte data at
unprecedented data interest rates we
notice there's still
some unanswered questions like for
example as a community
these are some of the challenges that
some of the challenges that we should be
aware of as we move from a terabyte to a
petabyte to a zettabyte scale
should we be meshing on demand such that
only meshes
of those segmentations ids that are
requested by the user be presented
or perhaps this could potentially reduce
the cost of storing the actual meshes
while retaining the advantages of the
annotations
um should we take a step further and
segment on demand
segment segmenting only areas of
interest and building from there
may be more cost efficient you may
should we maybe
also just mesh in a volume based way
where
that where we segment the entire volumes
or do we gain more from segmenting a
single process in the entire span of the
data set
which might be more efficient as we
store all this data we also need to
think about the resolutions
res 0 data is rarely used to run
segmentations algorithm
so is it interesting if we just down
sample it and then not keep it
what's the lowest resolution that is
actually useful to researchers
and how do we make the engis process
easier because as we move towards larger
data sets our infrastructure needs to be
able to handle
many more writes per second in order to
ingest the data as quickly as possible
finally how do we make sure that as we
that as our data size
scales up we continue to make
groundbreaking discoveries
we hope to continue this discussion with
you in our bossdb slack to which you can
find the link on on this slide
our last slide as a team
we would like to just thank iopro
microns program along with the nih for
funding the boss db and super projects
and i'd like to personally thank the apl
brain team with whom
none of this work would be possible i'm
finally a big thank you to the
organizers of this symposia thank you
very much
i'd like to just introduce our next
speaker denis cassares
hello my name is denise cazares and i am
a rising junior at johns hopkins
university i am majoring in cognitive
science with focal areas in
computational approaches and
neuroscience
today i am representing one of the
circuit program cohorts at jhu's applied
physics laboratory
as part of apl brain i'm going to share
with you some information
on our mission to democratize the field
of connectomics
before i delve into our project i want
to briefly acknowledge and introduce
circuit
which stands for cohort based integrated
research community for undergraduate
innovation and trailblazing
it is a program for trailblazing
students with high potential but that
are having difficulty achieving their
goals
because of various barriers in their way
the goal of the circuit experience is to
educate future leaders in areas of stem
such as data science machine learning
and artificial intelligence
there is a holistic approach in
recruitment and it is a 14-month
commitment with training in technical
areas professional development and
team-based projects
to make significant contributions in the
world of science
there are challenges that are important
to consider in the scope of this mission
the first is scalability with advances
in technology
big data is ever more pervasive and
necessary for the kinds of questions
being investigated
big data in this case is at the pedestal
level and to be able to handle this
amount of data we are having to rely on
cloud computing resources
another aspect of scalability is to be
able to customize workflows
into more digestible chunks the second
challenge to consider is reproducibility
it is necessary to be able to reproduce
results from colleagues to be able to
further the field
this helps generate baseline connectomes
for comparison and other experimental
conditions
accessibility is the third challenge
computational complexities often get in
the way of running workflows on these
large datasets
because of this an intuitive tool is
desirable for connectome generation and
analysis
in addition access shouldn't be limited
so an open source approach would
help to democratize connectomics to
reiterate there is a high demand in the
field to streamline the process of
generating connectomes and graphs for
analysis
but in a more intuitive manner
apl confronted the challenge of
scalability by developing a
state-of-the-art toolkit and volumetric
database
subear and bossdb for scalability and
rec accessibility
we propose a web portal that merges the
capabilities of both ecosystems
into an accessible centralized location
this streamlines the process for
reproducible assessment of existing and
novel electron microscopy
neuroimaging data sets the scientific
portal will allow researchers to focus
on answering the questions
that will inform our understanding of
the connectome the user-friendly
graphical user interface
caters to researchers with diverse
computational backgrounds
writing code is no longer required to
run a workflow since user specifications
in the portal can easily
be translated into scripts
our approach can be simplified in the
following schematic
we created a web portal that can
authenticate with bossdb
to access what are currently publicly
available data sets
next users can initiate a new job
current capabilities are with the public
data sets but we are
developing capabilities for users to
upload their own data sets for
processing
then users specify what processing tools
they wish to use on the data set
the workflow specified will determine
which parameters can be customized
after parameters are filled in the
workflow is triggered and the specific
interdependencies and order of tasks
are handled in the background so the
user doesn't have to deal with them and
to simplify the process
as the data set is processed there is a
periodic check-in to see if the workflow
is complete with api calls to the apache
airflow task scheduler
these are large data sets so the
processing can take some time
from a few minutes to a few hours
depending on the complexity
but with the ability to customize the
workflows it is easier to minimize wait
time
and still extract valuable information
once the workflow is complete it is
returned to the user to download or
visualize
a neural glancer there are some
preliminary analysis tools and
development that are being made more
user-friendly
i want to thank the boss db and sub-air
teams for facilitating collaboration
with us
and for their ongoing support through
the project
lastly a big thank you to all those
involved in today's presentation
next i would like to introduce jennifer
stitzel
hi everyone i'm a fourth year phd
candidate at the university of
pennsylvania i'm in danny bassett and
tim lucas's labs
and today i'm going to talk about using
epileptic spikes to understand how human
functional brain networks respond to
perturbations
so i want to start by talking about why
i chose
an epilepsy project for the symposium
it's because i really think that
epilepsy is well characterized as
a network disease and i think that's
largely because a lot of the features of
epilepsy
have to do with synchrony between brain
regions so the only
consistent and defining feature of
epilepsy is a predisposition to seizures
so we have an image of a specific kind
of seizure a generalized seizure up here
on the right seizures will
generally start at um a specific brain
region called the seizure onset zone
it's indicated by this black circle here
but it will very quickly spread
across the entire brain so you can see
these really synchronous
high amplitude oscillations across the
entire brain
where each of these lines here is a
recording from a different brain region
so that's a seizure there are some other
interesting features of synchrony
that are prominent in epilepsy as well
so for example different phases of
seizures have
different patterns of synchrony and you
can even see these changes
hours before seizure starts and they can
be predictive of
when a patient is going to seize so
because of that
i do think epilepsy is well suited for
tools from network neuroscience network
science
and complex systems and essentially to
use these tools what we're going to do
is characterize the brain
as the set of discrete brain regions
indicated on this picture
by these uh grayscale circles and the
connections between them
where the connections between them here
are this uh they're going to be like the
synchrony that i've been talking about
so essentially it's just how similar the
activity is between brain regions
i think this framework can be useful for
translational research but also
just for basic neuroscience research
into
characterizing the brain as a complex
system and my talk is going to focus on
that latter part
and in complex systems research once
you've defined your system
a good way to study it and learn about
its properties is to observe how it
responds to perturbations
so if you change one of these regions
the activity
how does that affect the rest of the
network
and epilepsy gives us a really unique
opportunity to study this because of a
specific waveform that we see in
epilepsy called an epileptic spike
so now we see a spike on the right it
looks different
from the seizure it still starts or
tends to start in the same region so
it's also starting at the seizure onset
zone
but you'll notice that the spike is
localized it doesn't spread to the
entire brain
and while most patients don't notice
when these spikes are happening
there is some evidence that they're
having some kind of distributed effects
so for example some other imp um some
other features of brain activity such as
spindles
will be affected by spikes even when the
spindles are located
outside the seizure onset zone
additionally spikes will affect
tap performance if they're happening
while the patient is engaged in
something cognitively demanding
so despite you know this evidence that
these spikes even though they're a focal
artifact are affecting the
entire brain uh the extent to which they
perturb these sort of global measures of
synchrony has not yet been quantified
and i think there are a lot of reasons
for this but one major challenge
um standing in the way is that epilepsy
is very heterogeneous and i think
answering this question
really thoroughly would require first of
all high quality
electrophysiological data where we can
estimate the synchrony between brain
regions well
and also a lot of people so we can get
something you know close to a
representative sample so luckily for us
this data and all of those tools are now
available and so we can start to answer
this so we're going to be using
data collected by a really big
collaborative group that was led by mike
kahana at the university of pennsylvania
of 250 people with electrochordatography
data
electrochordatography is a source level
recording it's electrophysiological data
recorded from
electrodes that have been implanted into
somebody's brain
and for this project i'm going to show
you some preliminary data
from about 180 of these 250 people
so specifically what we're going to do
is we're going to take all this data
we're going to pre-process it and then
we're going to try and automatically
find
where these epileptic spikes are you can
see they're
indicated on this toy time series with
these gold circles
after that we're going to break the data
up into one second windows
and we're going to break the data up
into frequency bands this is a common
thing to do with electrophysiological
data
where we break it into slow all the way
to fast oscillations
then within each frequency band and
within each window
we're going to look at a bunch of
different estimates of functional
connectivity
i'm only going to talk about three of
them here the first one
is an amplitude envelope correlation
this is essentially just a correlation
it's telling you how similar the
amplitude of two brain regions is over
time
the next one is the phase locking value
which has nothing to do with amplitude
all the phase locking value is telling
you is whether two regions have a
consistent phase offset over time
and then the last measure is coherence
which is sort of like a mix
between the two it's quantifying similar
phase but it's also weighted by the
amplitude of each
brain region so once we have
all of those functional connectivity
measures what we're going to do is use
robust regression to try and estimate
the effect
of these epileptic spikes on the
strength of the functional connectivity
and we're going to have two different
predictors to estimate this one of them
is
a binary and just says in each time
window is there a spike or not
and the other one is continuous and
gives the number of spikes in each time
window
and the last thing i want to mention
before getting into the results is that
we are also including
power as a covariate um the band limited
power
is just a way of estimating the amount
of brain activity
so any changes that we see are going to
be above and beyond what would be
explained by just
changes in brain activity uh resulting
from the spikes
okay so this is the format that i'm
going to present most of my results in
it's a lot of data so i want to kind of
go over
the axes of this first we're going to
have our two different predictors
the number of spikes and the binary just
presence of spike
on the y-axis and then the
all the different bands are going to be
on the x-axis
and each measure is going to be a
different color uh within these plots
okay so first thing we want to do is
just address this very basic question of
are there are there effects do epileptic
spikes
impact functional connections in the
brain and what we see
is that um these red asterisks are
indicating significance
they're not locally local localized to
um specific bands
but instead are localized to um specific
measures
so what we see here is that selectively
in these amplitude based measures so the
amplitude
envelope correlation and coherence we
see that a single spike will disrupt
these functional connections and leading
to decreases in the strength
and then more spikes after that will
sort of build that back up again
and i do want to mention that all of the
bright red asterisks replicated with
another spike detector
as well as an orthogonalized version of
the amplitude envelope
correlation okay so the next
question we want to ask is whether these
effects are really driven
only by the seizure onset zone where the
spikes are starting or if they're
spreading to the rest of the network
and so to do this rather than just
looking at raw effect sizes
what we're going to do is um get the
value from the seizure onset zone and
subtract it from
the value we get in the rest of the
brain so this plot is now going to show
a difference between effects rather than
just the effect itself and what we see
is that for most of these we get a
really tight distribution around zero so
there are not very big differences
but none of these are significant after
multiple comparisons correction
these gray asterisks are indicating um
things that were significant before
multiple comparisons correction
the interpretation here is that it seems
like these effects really are affecting
distal regions
even though the spikes themselves are
extremely focal
okay next what we want to do is try and
parse some of this variability
across all of these individuals and so
one potential source of variability
could be where
these spikes are originating from so if
you look at these
toy brain networks you might imagine
that a spike that starts at this orange
node
would have set the network differently
than a spike that starts at this green
node
and a lot of the theory and complex
system says that's because um
these two nodes have different
connections so they're going to affect
the network differently
so we wanted to try to test this in a
pretty basic way that was going to be
robust to electro localization because
that could be a noisy process
what we're going to do is compare the
seizure onset zones by hemisphere
so language lateralization induces a lot
of changes in connectivity
so we're going to test if there's a
difference in these effect sizes
for subjects that have their seizure
onset zone ipsilateral to their dominant
hand
as opposed to contralateral what we see
is that selectively in these lower
frequencies the
theta and alpha bands the when the
seizure onset zone is ipsilateral to
their dominant hand we get larger
effects
and so one potential interpretation of
this
is that something about that
contralateral hemisphere something about
the architecture of it is preventing the
further spread
of these focal perturbations in the
future i'd really like to dig into this
a little bit more
and get a finer scale breakdown than
just the hemisphere
okay so the last thing that i'm going to
talk about today is whether the
magnitude of these
effects on resting data um predicts task
performance
so in this data sets individuals
completed
you know some of some subset of five
tasks
and since performance and all those
tasks is really highly correlated and
they're pretty similar
what we're going to do is just take the
individuals who completed a couple of
them
and get the average of their performance
and what we find is that selectively
with
beta coherence we get a significant
effect where
a larger change to functional
connectivity resulting from epileptic
spikes
actually leads to better performance
and so in order to get a more meaningful
interpretation out of this
i'd like to analyze some task data and
potentially do some
statistical causal modeling and also
look for mediation by some different
clinical variables
so that is in the works with a really
quick summary
we've you know characterized the brain
as a functionally interacting complex
network
we've shown that these focal
perturbations spread and affect the
entire network
that that effect is mediated by where
the spike starts and
that in some cases the magnitude of that
effect tracks with behavior
and now i'd like to thank everyone in my
lab everyone at the hospital
and the people who collected the data
for helping me complete this project
and now i'd like to hand it off to the
next speaker
dr kristen harris
good morning thank you very much for
inviting me to present some of our work
at this meeting today
i'm going to be talking to you today
about enhanced resolution for
3d electron microscopy analysis of
synapses
and this work is powered by our nsf
neuronex award
and i'm very grateful to the nsf for
this opportunity
so my goal today is to fill the
resolution
field size gap with scanning electron
microscopy
operating in the transmission mode which
we are expanding
to tomography on the scanning electron
microscope
so scanning electron microscopy in the
transmission mode or tcm
has been really developed on standard
instrumentation
um in this case the zeiss supra 40
and was published in our paper back in
2013.
transmission scanning electron
microscopy allows us to have very large
fields
much larger than the standard
transmission
em field um on the upright microscope
as you can see we just needed to have
about six or seven
fields to montage the entire
dendritic arbor of a pyramidal cell for
example
and yet while operating the transmission
mode
we maintain the two nanometer xy
resolution
that's needed to visualize small
structures like polyribosomes
microtubules vesicles in detail
well what we want to do is to be able to
integrate
this cell biology of the neuron and
synapses
into understanding neural circuits
so the first thing that we're doing is
improving alignment of these large
fields
using the swift ir and the gui that's
been implemented in our laboratory in
collaboration with our colleagues out at
the salk institute and the texas
advanced computing center
so if you look at the quick video here
the original
absence of alignments on the left field
that's going to be working with is in
the middle
and the aligned version is over here at
the right and so
the user gets to enter all sorts of
features to improve the alignment
check the alignment do it at different
scales to make sure that it's absolutely
perfect by the end of the day
so we need also though to have em
tomography
to reveal substructure that's buried in
the sections that are cut
to visualize an electron microscope
these are two serial sections from the
same dendritic spine
that has a spine apparatus that critical
structure i showed you that seems to
organize
the principles of long-term potentiation
synapses in two adjacent sections
we really want to know how much surface
area is ascribed to this
lipid-producing calcium-regulating
organelle
we would really like to be able to see
those structures in detail and be able
to not have this overlap of these gray
walls that are shown here on adjacent
sections
we also need em tomography to overcome
the fragility of the thin sections that
are photographed
either in the transmission electron
microscope or typically in the
scanning microscope using backscatter
and these
sections include these artifacts include
folds which you can see here
or tears that occur in these fragile
sections and
this is one of the biggest problems with
alignment and
auto segmentation that is going forward
so but the tomography that is available
right now is that that's in the upright
transmission electron microscope and
it's really quite limited by the small
field size to about one micron squared
but you can see in this very thick
section this is 150 nanometer thick
section that there are structures that
can't be
resolved until we make the virtual
section so i'm just going to show you
that same
field where virtual sections have been
calculated from a tomogram
and you can see in quite detail the
membranes of each part of that spine
apparatus
you can see the vesicles very clearly
you can see a microtubule you can see
where the extracellular space is
and you can even see a clear example of
a polyribosome emerging on these
sections here
so tomosem is really using tomography
now on these large
trans scanning electron microscope
fields operating in the transmission
mode
these fields a single field can be up to
10 000 microns squared 100 microns on
the side
they we can have the much thicker
sections because we can do tomography
we've tested up to 300 nanometers now
so for the same volumes that we
typically do 100 sterile sections we
only need to collect
40 that's less human cutting time
there's stronger sections
they do not require any um post-section
staining so we have the homogeneity of
on-block staining and there are many
fewer
or almost no flaws we've yet to see any
flaws in these thicker sections of the
nature of folds and tears
then we calculate virtual z sections and
that will reveal the varied structures
and provide for better auto segmentation
we estimate right now that we need about
25
images per section through the tomogram
and over 40 sections that's about a
thousand images taken
it's automatable for multiple image
multi-section and multi-grid
and this is an example of a 250
nanometer section
we're developing this on existing
platform um the zeiss um
merlin gemini 2 it's a relatively
inexpensive
instrumentation that is affordable at
the level of a
startup package has the a stem detector
custom grid holder five access eucentric
stage
here's this 250 nanometer thick section
in the transmission mode you can even
see your regions of interest and that 15
kv
provides good contrast throughout the
section depth
the tomosam operates now in a conical
tilt tomography we have a single tilt
one dynamic focus transform conventional
stage and detector the rotation is up to
220 degrees around a single detector
we're now trying to get rotation for 360
degrees with a second detector
so here's a short movie that illustrates
um
this new new this custom grid holder
uh which is on mounted on a five-axis
eucentric stage
the a-stem detector is below the merlin
field emission
scm field emitter is
located above and what happens is
we simply make the rotation of the tilt
and then one gets the cone by rotating
about that single tilt
we go to the region of a line of
interest and look up close
you watch for example as if we rotate
around this particular synapse you can
see there are planes in which it comes
into perfect cross-section
focus and we are now in the process of
developing um our next goal is to
compute the virtual z
sections at a resolution um
of two nanometers in x y z 10 to 15
nanometers will
disambiguate all structures that are
over line and any of the buried
structures
and these will be our xy fields for a
total scm volume
of about a cubic millimeter so our goals
have been filling this resolution field
size gap with tsem and tomosam
and i encourage you to see the virtual
poster by james carson
at this brain initiative meeting thanks
to everyone who's been involved
and next up will be eva dyer
thank you hello my name is eva dyer and
i'm an assistant professor at georgia
tech and emory and today i'll tell you
about the work that we've been doing in
my lab to use deep learning and machine
learning approaches to build multi-scale
maps of brain structure and organization
all right so uh to motivate a lot of the
work that we do in my lab as well as you
know one of the key motivations of this
workshop is um
being able to handle the sort of scale
and you know resolution that we're
currently dealing with in many of these
new
imaging modalities including electron
microscopy
and all different types of microscopy
data sets
and so with these large data sets we're
often faced with an issue of trying to
figure out
and interpret uh what's going on within
within these data sets and most of the
time we're actually facing with raw
images that we need to translate
into scientific insights
so the key kind of driving question
behind the work that i'll describe today
is a question that we are often faced
with when dealing with many different
types of neuroanatomical studies
and in particular question is what makes
brain areas distinct
when looking at an image of many
different brain areas
there are you know key features in the
underlying micro architecture anatomy
that you know strike us or stand out
and based upon those observations this
is actually how we go about
as anatomists defining what constitutes
different brain areas so
in this example i'm just showing a
large-scale x-ray micro tomography data
set that was captured at
one micron isotropic resolution and here
i'm showing a sample that spans all the
way from somatosensory cortex down to
hypothalamus so it's a very diverse
sample and if we zoom into all the
different regions therein
we see that um distributions and axons
which are shown here in bright white
uh distributions of cell bodies or blood
vessels
are strikingly different and so um
you know these are really the key
questions and so we were interested in
whether or not we could actually train a
neural network or an
automated solution to be able to find
these patterns
without having to take in training data
that tells it
necessarily what to look for so to do
this we developed a
tool which we call deep brain disco or
deep brain discovery
essentially the idea is shown here in
this overview slide so
what we do is we start by zooming into
very small local snapshots within these
different brain regions
we essentially train a neural network to
then discriminate between these six
different brain regions shown over here
on the left
so discriminating between regions of
cortex or stratum or thalamus
or um or different paths of white matter
after we train this neural network we
then go and we actually open it up so we
open up this black box and we actually
use the neural network as a feature
extractor so instead of using it just to
classify
the brain regions into different areas
we are um
we're extracting the features from this
network and then what we do is we use
applied um
mathematics tools or matrix
factorization techniques
to then take those representations from
the network
rotate them and embed them into a lower
dimensional space
once we have that we can actually start
to zoom
in to regions of the sample that we
might not have
already um trained the network to
discover
so this is now just showing some kind of
highlights of the results
um from this from the strategy so what
i'm showing here in the middle
are overlays now where we're embedding
these network
activations onto different parts of the
brain and so what we see
immediately is that you know our network
it has been trained to discriminate
across these different areas
it can do a good job initially of just
dividing
uh the brain regions into parts but we
also see some really interesting effects
like
different parts of cortex being linked
with different parts of thalnus
which is something that you know the
network hasn't been trained to do
um we can zoom in even further and if we
actually look into these representations
within cortex we find that there is
there are laminar differences or
basically the layers within cortex have
been revealed
through this particular strategy and we
can zoom in even further and find that
this network has actually
pulled out some interesting parts of the
data that correspond to higher or lower
cellular density regions so essentially
what this network has done without
being told to do so is it's found a lot
of interesting patterns of
microarchitecture
directly from the data using these
data-driven representations
we can also expand upon this and
actually train the network
to also segment at the pixel level which
is something we've seen
um in some of the other presentations
today and so we can create now a
multi-skill map
of both different brain areas and the
underlying micro architecture they're in
i just wanted to quickly say that we've
released this data
through the boss db so bossdb.org
this is an open access publicly
available x-ray microtomography data set
with
tons of heterogeneous brain areas and we
have multiple annotations and
segmentations provided as well
and in summary we've provided a new
neural network solution
for being able to extract features from
brain images and reveal things like
different cell densities or even barrels
within cortex
we can couple this with other structural
segmentation tools to find a multi-scale
map and we've also
told you a bit about this new
interactive x-ray
micro ct atlas and segmentations that
are now on boss db
and with that i will uh acknowledge our
team
and also our collaborators including um
will gray roncall at the apl
um who also hosted a symposium really
great opportunity
our funding sources including the nih
and i'd like to thank you all for your
attention thanks
up next we have steve plaza
hello i'm honored to present on behalf
of the genealia uh fly em
research team at genealogy um in
collaboration with google
um our group has been working on
connectomix for
about 10 years um obviously in the fly
as our
indicates and our group has really
worked on
the whole pipeline the whole
infrastructure from imaging
acquisition of the data to alignment
segmentation synapse annotations and
producing the connectomic product
so it's almost like a factory and we've
produced i think a lot of
connectomes over the course of the last
several years
prominently in the last few years we've
worked on this sample called the hemi
brain
this contains a large portion of the fly
brain fly central region
and the goals of us analyzing of
reconstructing a connectome for this
volume
was to understand various um behaviors
and
and properties of fly such as
associative learning
sleep understand navigation better but
there's another goal which is to
facilitate science in the community and
to make the data set accessible
now one thing i just want to point out
quickly is that this is a dense connect
home so we're
trying to get all the neurons all the
connections as much as we can
for a given region
um and as you can see um you know in
this movie um
you're not gonna you don't look at this
movie to understand or to see
the exact details there's a lot of stuff
going on here we're only showing the
subset of the neurons
but i think the thing to highlight here
is the complexity and
this data set even though it's just the
fly uh in the spirit of this plata and
exascale
bonds that we're looking at um you know
has over 20 000 neurons
that we've reconstructed there's tens of
millions of synapses in the data set
um we're only showing a small section um
of the data here because
it's just it's very overwhelming to look
at frankly and i think that's an
important thing to remember when we're
talking about
uh these connectomes is that um i think
there's a lot of great technology that's
been developed but there's actually not
that many connectomes we heard about
obviously sidney brenner and
the worm scale there's a couple other
small model organisms and then the fly
now is
is the biggest one that's out there the
challenges that are involved
is is actually not so much even
acquiring the data and segmenting data
which of course is a big challenge with
actually generating the connectivity
graph itself
it involves a lot of manual labor a lot
of proofreading in the process
um and with better segmentation of
course we expect the validation time to
be significantly better
um but still for the nf1 for the first
time that you do something it's going to
require validation time
and and so we've heard from jeff talk
about a lot of the challenges that are
involved but
i do want to emphasize that the that the
gray scale
the em data the segmentation even is a
means to an end
um the end is the is what you can
analyze in the connectome
and i think actually that is the biggest
challenge is to make it uh the most
consumable possible um you could see
here
that we developed a few tools um to help
with this one of the things i just want
to highlight
is some of our proofreading tools that
we worked on these are high level
um tools for looking at neuron shapes
and trying to figure if there's any
errors in the reconstruction
now we show a little uh inset here of
grayscale
but notably it's not even clear that we
really need grayscale many times to do a
proofreading
and actually one of the longer term
goals that our group has is to try to
eliminate even needing em data to
reconstruct
the connectome so you could imagine the
connectome in the neuron shapes could
potentially even fit in a laptop even if
it's a mouse scale connect them
and so that type of model order
reduction i think is critical for making
the data sets accessible
to the community um i won't talk about
synapse validation but we do have a
rigorous system of iterating
with machine learning and spot checking
those results
um to make the data accessible um we try
to split up the the volume into several
canonical brain regions um we can use
the connector to help guide this process
just a little bit of breaking things
down hierarchically
we define cell types to also break down
the complexity of the data now cell
types a little bit of a slippery term
um but there are different ways that you
could use connectivity to help at least
tease out
some differences between neurons that
might otherwise look morphologically
very similar
and then also we've introduced a tool
called new newprint to help us analyze
this data
this is a graph database that we can use
to represent the data so users can
navigate very quickly
but importantly we also stir the data in
a hierarchical way so we can look at
regions of interest and bore down into
the connectivity graph or more detailed
skeleton data if needed
which as it turns out most of the time
people don't really want as beautiful as
em data is
most of our users just care about the
result and i think that's
some of the lessons that we've learned
is that it's very important i think to
have a very agile mindset
we've done a lot of rapid prototyping we
did a lot of iterations we try a lot of
volumes
at small scale and to make sure that it
scales up but also the management is
very critical the mission before the
papers we always focused on getting the
connectomic result
we have a mixture of labs that work with
us with some kind of like centralized
guided steering committee
and i think those types of
infrastructure get more and more
important
as you deal with these diverse
interdisciplinary teams um i would like
to thank you for your attention and now
introduce a new new
pasta for the next talk
thank you for the opportunity to present
in this symposium my name is minoo
maserik de kosta
and in my presentation i'm going to
discuss linking
cell pipes with electron microscopy
based connectomics
and for that i'm going to use a set of
data sets
collected under the iarpa microns
program
in a collaboration that has been
collected by the alan institute
princeton university and baylor college
of medicine
so cell types are one of the most
fundamental concepts
in neuroscience and connectivity can
some
connectomics can contribute to it using
connectivity
of course but also the single cell
pathology and you can see here in the
center
an example of a beautifully segmented
neuron from one of our em data sets done
by
sebastian swindwell however there are
many other
properties that are not immediately
registered with kineconomic data sets as
for example
synapse physiology or transcriptomics
however and increasingly together with
these other data sets
morphology is also collected and so
morphology can be used
as a we set a phone between these
modalities
and kinecomics this is by far not the
only way to link
these modalities but it is the way that
it's possible uh
right now
and as a first example i'm going to use
um our recent study
on the structural and functional logics
assembly itself
and in this video you see the
reconstruction from em in grey
is the accent initial segment of the way
to three pyramidal cells individual
cortex of the mouth and in color there
are many different from the axons
and you see that for there are some
criminal cells that receive very few
sinuses while
others receive even up to 10 times more
and the connectomics part of our study
allows us to map the complete
connectivity between these two cell
types
but actually one of
our major conclusions that the sunday
cells carry
a global inhibitory signal that is
adjusted to each one of its targets will
not have been possible by
ten economics alone and and so
using morphology we're able to link our
anatomic studies with the synthetic cell
lines
used with transgenic transgenic mouse
lines
uh using these small clients were able
to perform some of the first
away behaving recordings of the song via
cells
now for other examples i'm going to use
a different
data file this is a much larger data set
it's on the petascale range it's a cubic
millimeter of cortex collected with
transmission electron microscopy
it goes across several visual areas
and you see in this video uh
an example of um some of its
reconstructions it contains
approximately a hundred thousand neurons
with some in the volume
and here's a few examples of uh of a
layer two three cell in rl in dark blue
on the left side
and some of its uh and some of its uh
targets both locally
and distally um and uh
and now what we can do and what the
forest covenant did
is to classify uh neurons in this data
set
um using basically the same
methods that were used uh in in
in studies with uh from from slice
physiology
and in this case um in this case you can
see here results of
a study of cohens and sorensen at all
from 2019 so
in color you see the the
morphological clusters of cell types
from the
slice study and in black you see the
results
of the of the methodological
classification from the
from the rpm data set and you can see
that they match
pretty pretty nicely and that's what
that
allows us to do now is from the
connectomic side
to map the connectivity patterns of this
neuron and here's an example collected
by agnes potter
across several layer five sector cells
and
from from the the slice
uh the science work we can connect
mathematic physiology
electrophysiological properties or
translatomics with touch sick
and morphology allows us to link this
this uh modalities and i think that
would be
a very powerful link so to finalize
uh i wanna say that uh some of our data
sets are already
obviously accessible to everyone please
use them the more you use them the more
you encourage
another to to release the data to the
public and also to say that
even though i thought with neurons the
n-data cells are much richer than
neurons there's earlier there's lots
which are there's organelles
as you've heard earlier uh from alicia's
talk and and and to finalize i'm just
going to show a short
video again from a beautiful automatic
communication from sebastian
in labs in this data set in purple
there's a microglia
uh next to a lato3 pyramidal cell
and to end i want to thank everyone from
particular clay reed which is ahead of
our department at the rna series but
also our collaborators both internally
um and externally uh particularly the
labor fasting student andrea tulias
and of course our founder mr paul lauren
great thank you all to all of our
presenters who did a great job of
presenting on the current state of art
for the field both for science and
engineering as well as framing some of
the challenges that we foresee as we
move forward
and as the scale for these data sets
increases
my name is brock wester i'm moderating
this session
with will grey ronkl we're now in the
panelist discussion
um question answer session of the
meeting
we got some questions from the audience
during the presentations but as a
reminder
please continue to submit questions for
panelists
and we'll answer as many as we can
within the session
and we'll start with some specific
questions to each of the panelists
uh jeff you talked about the benefits of
building a connectome for an entire
mouse brain
how would you compare the importance of
this goal to that of comparative
connectomics
where we image smaller regions from
multiple organisms
in different scientific studies uh
thanks brock
i i think both of those goals are
admirable and i couldn't qualitatively
say one is better than the other
but it's important to realize i think
that doing a whole
animals connect home offers a kind of
information that
is never available by doing small
regions
and and that comes from the painful
realization that no matter how big
a region of the brain you look at a
substantial number of the
neurons that are entering that region
are coming from cells that are
far flung sometimes many many
millimeters away
from the cells you're looking at and for
that reason
if one ever wants to have a sense of how
neurons that project from one part of
the brain to another
uh make synaptic connections on which
particular cells in which particular
layers for example one is going to have
to have
a whole brain at one point or another
that's not to say there are not very
important questions with comparative
connectomics
uh and maybe uh in a subsequent question
i'll talk about that
great thank you jeff i was just gonna
say maybe as a as a follow-up to that uh
nuno i wonder if you might have thoughts
on
on which approach uh makes the most
sense
i'm just gonna say that i i agree with
chefs and but i would like to add that
in the process of scaling the
technologies
to be able to collect the exo-scale
miles connectome
there's going to be many better scale
data sets that are going to be
needed to in that in that in that
process and
and will basically i think will make
generating petascale data sets a kind of
standard and therefore allowing also
those
those comparisons across inter
individuals interspecies
inter areas and and so forth so i it's
not i don't see it
really as a as a one or the other i i
see it as them
almost happening simultaneously and in
the process of scaling up to the
exoscale
mass connector
you know thanks so much um okay eva
what is the role of other imaging
modalities as an en
scaling up the reconstructed connectomes
or capturing their anatomy
from larger organisms
um hi yeah it's a great question i mean
i think today
we heard a lot of talks that focused on
electron microscopy and then i also
spoke about x-ray microtomography which
is
essentially using a similar preparation
to em
to achieve a dense labeling of
essentially
well in the case of em as we saw in many
of the talks i mean
every single piece of membrane you know
bound
tissue so you can see everything and
it's a very dense reconstruction
um but you know on in in
terms of a lot of other emerging
technologies that use
sparse labeling um techniques along with
light microscopy we're able to
augment this dense view right that we
get from em
with other types of information or
antibodies
information about cell types and while
we might not see that in the same dense
picture we can imagine a lot of tools
being developed in the future to
integrate
this sort of dense and also sparse
understanding of the underlying
micro architecture and anatomy and
so yeah i think moving forward we'll i
imagine that we'll see a lot of
new emerging tools that use both
experimental and also computational
techniques
to build multi-modal and sort of
multi-dimensional views
of the brain and also the connections
and
circuits they're in
thank thanks eva so maybe our our next
question
for uh for kristen harris um
so so kristen um of course
collecting all this big data um is
necessary but
but not sufficient um when we think
about
that that process of acquiring the raw
data and processing it and doing
analysis
uh what should we be thinking about as a
community to
ensure that we're collecting the right
data and helping to make it available to
the community
scientists and engineers
thanks a lot for that question and as
many of the people in this group will
know that i have been really
pushing hard to collect this data at two
nanometer
xy resolutions so that the kinds of data
that we saw alyssa present but even
more refined data can be studied in the
context of cell biology in the future
and so i really
am pushing hard that we don't go after
a lower resolution data set
that will maybe get us the synaptome but
not get us
the synaptic weight ohm and not allow us
to really understand how the cell
biology
of those connections works so
that's that's one of the things that i'm
pushing really hard for
um and i know that that's going to uh
increase the amount of time it takes to
get this but the other beauty of pushing
for that resolution
is that i think in in the same vein that
nuno brought up
it will provide the development
of much better tools along the way for
analyzing the data
and furthermore for segmenting and
training
tools to segment it the better the
resolution of the images
both in x and y and ultimately in z
will make that aspect of it much
more reliable and faster and so i
i think we are soon going to come to the
bottleneck at the analysis
and not at the image acquisition end and
so i'm hoping that
what all those who begin to work on the
mouse connect home will do is
consider the importance of having really
high resolution data as they collect the
data
the other point that i make over and
over again is that
collecting a lot of metadata before the
the mouse that gets selected or the 10
mice that gets selected
for creating the mouse connect home
collecting a lot of metadata about their
behavior their development
the normality of their brains relative
to other animals on other
at other scales will be really critical
i think for people to be able to
view it as an atlas that new data coming
up can be
scaled against that metadata from new
animals and not
simply rely on the anatomy as the
component of the atlas that will
ultimately make this data really
outstanding thank you
okay thanks kristin this next question
will go to
steve during the symposium today
on neuroai and neurodynamics uh the
discussion
uh talks a little bit about the
potential metric for assessing data
quality or usefulness
of a neural data set to current or
potential
scientific questions or challenges how
can we go about reading
these imaging and connectomics data sets
to benefit the community
um thanks brock for um the question um
it's definitely a challenging question
because i think the the
the biggest thing is is sort of what
what is important for people
and sort of what i've been finding um
and working um with the yum for several
years now is that
i often find that people don't have the
right questions uh in the first place
um there's a lot in the data set there's
a lot that you can view in the data set
um that is much more nuanced much more
intricate than what
people are asking so i think there are
definitely some advanced things that we
could do
but for at least questions that people
ask what we've done practically before
let's say if you care about
whether you can see all the synapses or
mitochondria or whether you can
do the connectome accurately we try to
practically assess the situation by
measurement
um so obviously this would entail maybe
imaging something in different
modalities
or um trying things at different
resolutions and seeing
if we're missing anything um in our
production scale
um for the connect term that we had done
in the fly we started out with small
regions and we scaled up and each time
we scaled up
we measured very carefully we saw before
to make sure that we could extrapolate
those techniques with bigger
data sets of so-called similar quality
but like i said i think the question is
the question
and trying to understand exactly what he
wants critical
great uh thanks steve and so i think uh
next up we have uh we have nuno
um who's responding to an audience
question
from uh terry suzanowski um and so so
terry asks
the cost of sequencing a human genome
has decreased exponentially
uh from a billion dollars to a thousand
dollars in 20 years
and he wonders if connectomics will
benefit from a similar exponential
decrease
i'll show this to nuno first
yeah i i think that i think that is i
think that is very much possible
um currently
a large proportion of the of the of the
cost on the date
is is is not so much the acquisition but
it's the
storage of the data and all the
computation um
required to segment to segment the
neurons and their synapse and their
organelles from the data and so as
as as that cost of computation decreases
so will the cost associated with
collecting this data will decrease as
well
uh thanks for that nuno and uh steve i
wonder if you might have uh
some feedback on that question from your
experience at genealia
um and from my perspective the dominant
cost has always been the proofreading
so again i think the reason oftentimes
the other costs are more visible is
because
that's that's sort of still where we're
at it's very hard to extract the connect
home
um i think there's a few things that we
can do to lower the cost across the
board
um at least for the imaging part you
know we've benefited techno
technologically speaking with industries
involved
so if there's some way to convince uh
computer manufacturers that building
microscopes is a great thing
somehow gets into their bottom line that
would be one way to really reduce costs
on
some of the acquisitions um for machine
learning
um yes compute compute will go faster
but i think
um one of the things that we could do is
that a lot of times we're wasting a lot
of compute cycles for things that are
easier
so maybe doing our compute a little bit
smarter make sure that we're targeting
um the compute that we really need for
areas that are a little bit harder to to
analyze is a good way to reduce costs
there and then finally for proofreading
i think we're just seeing that as a
consequence of the improvements
um upfield um in the last 10 years we
started out where
a fly connector would require maybe even
tens of thousands of proofreader
editor years and we believe we have that
down to maybe a couple hundred years so
we're looking at you know a couple
orders of magnitude um just in the last
two years and i or ten years and i think
we could probably get another few racks
as we do our next connect home in the
next couple years
great thanks steve nuno um jeff what
what challenges are opportunities do
individual differences between subjects
introduced uh individuality elegance are
likely
uh to be very similar similar but for
other organisms and other species there
are going to be
differences how do we account for that
well this is a great question and uh
i participated in that study i i showed
of the eight connectors and to our
uh surprise uh 40
of the neuron to neuron connections even
in c elegans were different
from one animal to another and these
were isogenic animals
um so i think variability in wiring
diagrams is something you're going to
have to deal with no matter what species
you look at maybe the most interesting
thing is that that variability has many
sources
and some of them we don't understand why
they exist
why would isogenic animals have
different
wiring diagrams to some degree one
answer to that question might be that
some of their wiring diagram is
instantiated based on the
individual experiences of that animal we
don't think of that very much
when we think of worms but it really
hasn't been ruled out
but when we think about mammal uh brains
uh and all vertebrate brains where a
good deal of learning
is stably maintained for the life of the
animal
it's a reasonable hypothesis that that
information is going to be instantiated
in the wiring diagram
and therefore different animals will
have different wiring diagrams
and the challenge here is how to harness
this variability to learn something as
opposed to seeing it as an
obstacle because the differences which
always are asked and whenever anyone
talks to me about connectomics
one of the first questions is how can
you make sense of something if
everyone is a little different from
every other one
i think learning how those differences
get into the
wiring diagram and what their purpose is
where that variability comes from
is one of the fundamental challenges and
one of the ways to do that is looking at
a lot of animals
and i should say just going back to this
question of expense
there are huge expenses for
infrastructure
building wiring diagrams but once the
machines are there
using them for another wiring diagram is
very very inexpensive so once the
infrastructure exists
one can ask many questions and i think
one of the kinds of questions one would
like to ask is
how does that region of the brain look
from one animal to another
animals that have for example very
similar age
uh gender uh cell
genetic line but may differ only in for
example their experiences
thanks
thanks jeff our next question is to to
eva
from carolina to gothel
apologies for the pronunciation and she
asks about
the capabilities of machine learning to
help in this field how we can use
machine learning to
do segmentation and identify uh
different
different aspects of the of the
the large neuroimaging data sets so
things like cell
cell types or regions of the brain
kind of where where are we with with
using computers to help to make sense of
all of this data
yeah it's a great question um i mean i
think in general
a lot of the progress that we've seen
has been you know tracking much of
what's happening
in machine learning which is you know
kind of exploding in terms of
applications across the
typically we have to provide
these systems with training data right
and training data as we've kind of heard
from many of the
presenters and even you know discussions
of proofreading right
uh being able to collect the amount of
training data required to often you know
detect these different objects of course
when you're
you know looking for different types of
objects now you have to retrain a
network to
to potentially be able to um find
these different types of structures
right and so i think
uh we are making tons of progress in
being able to solve these segmentation
challenges
using at this point you know large
amounts of training data and also large
amounts of proofreading
efforts afterwards however i think
you know as we're continuing to track
the progress of ml
i think that there's a lot of really
exciting advances that are happening
there in unsupervised and
self-supervised learning
and i believe that as we're continuing
to move to a place where we can
leverage previously collected data sets
and previously collected annotations and
not have to sort of
start from scratch each time we want to
find a new type of object
i think that we're going to see that the
capabilities of these
data sets will also kind of explode
exponentially
uh as we don't need as much training
data and we can actually
uh solve these hard transfer learning
problems so
um i think we're we're in a
position now where um all of this is
really ripe
for this next generation
of discovery in um in neuroanatomy in
brain
connectomics and structure
thank you um kristen uh
we're probably going to get into a
number of questions regarding structure
and function
and functional data sets um we'll start
with this uh the dynamics
of synapses how can it be studied using
the techniques that we've talked about
today
thanks very much for the question can
you hear me
yeah yep i think my music is off right
you can hear me right
yep okay good yeah so i think this is a
fantastic question and it's one that i
um get every time i give a talk
and i think one of the um
only ways that you can use electron
microscopy to study
dynamics of function is to do what we
call
time series 3dem so basically you
do comparisons between animals that have
undergone different treatments
and look at how structure differs under
those conditions or you look at brain
slices even as in the same brush
brain you can give cells and synapses
different experiences and compare them
which we do routinely
the the other piece that's becoming much
more standard now and that is to do
correlative light microscopy where you
follow the life history of an individual
synapse
and then begin to look at its
ultrastructural
characteristics following a particular
treatment like glutamate on caging but
then to go to the em level to learn
what structure function relationships
were occurring at the synapse that
underwent a change and the size of its
dendritic spine for example
and follow that up with organelle like
analysis at the electron microscopic
level
the the other strategy of course
is to begin to label
particular synapses that you can
expose with light or general rhodopsin
type labeling to an experience
and be able to compare synapses and do
this sort of sparse labeling
and compare synapses even on the same
dendrite
that have undergone activation
to neighboring ones that haven't at
least recently undergone the same
activation and this is another strategy
we and others are employing
to identify synapses that have
undergone particular changes
in the context of the circuit
surrounding them so i think all of these
strategies
as these microscopy tools improve
all of these strategies are going to
give us the opportunity to investigate
dynamics of the synapses in pretty
well-defined states
over over time so i i think going down
this
road is of getting better tools for the
full mouse connect home
and applying them in these other cost
contexts is going to give us a much
broader view of how structure and
function are related throughout the
brain
thanks kristin very much we have a
question for
for steve from ming zhen and his
question is
moving toward pedaskill and exa-scale
connectomics
one of the things that's really
important is to develop relevant
standards for the data the metadata and
computational models
as well as the experimental protocols so
that uh you know both the primary and
secondary data analyses
can be well understood and uh completed
and so wondered what your thoughts were
on this and how we might move toward
that as a field
uh thanks fantastic questioning um
i think this is this deserves probably
hours of conversation so i'll try to
answer it in a minute though
um we have i think several challenges
um across the pipelines and i think
each stage represents a certain amount
of risk and the problem that we have
when we go to peta
and an exascale is of course everything
gets multiplied
and so this this question is obviously
very important because anything that we
have that's not precise
is going to be magnified at those scales
and recover uh probably requires a level
of frankly industrial
standards that we typically don't do in
lab
um a few examples of this just across
the workflow
data acquisition the preparation of
samples it seems like each person kind
of has their own
kind of magic recipe for doing things
and and it actually adds a lot of risk i
mean
the sad case of a couple years ago we
lost a very key person
um in the field in this which actually
you know holds back it hurts the
community obviously as well
um that's one case um in terms of the
data itself
there's been conversations about how we
best store the data there have been
conferences that have existed
but that is something where the
standardization must be better i mean
even having platforms like you know
existed for github
you know for software has been very
instrument instrumental in allowing
people to get involved and to contribute
so having those types of platforms is
very
very important um you know in terms of
the
proofreading and how we actually analyze
the data itself
having a certain set of standards again
when you have hundreds of people that
are gonna be looking at the data
you know they have to to follow a
certain way of proofreading the data so
that you can ensure quality
and maybe last but not least the
segmentation you know for you would
think in some ways this would be easy
because we have um output that we care
about which is the segmented volume that
we can proofread and we have input which
are these different algorithms and you
want to match
and see how good the result is but
there's only been a handful of
challenged data sets that have been out
there
and those challenge data sets that exist
only fall focus on narrow measures
that don't actually measure as far as i
can tell the speed of proofrooting
how much or how much will impact the the
cost of doing connectomics
and so it's very important that all this
stuff really gets honed
and honed down and made it better if we
hope to do this this project going
forward
thanks so much um just want to make a
quick note for everyone
we are past the one o'clock uh time but
we will continue with some additional
questions
uh we're from getting a lot there still
streaming in um
next one goes to nuno so dr eve
smarter mentioned yesterday in her talk
that transcriptomics alone was not
enough for identifying cell types
what role can this community play in
this pursuit
i think this community can play at least
two two important roles
one of them is uh mapping the
connectivity of uh of different cells
and from
from there itself from the connectivity
creates a classification
of cell types and we have seen we have
seen that
that now in this in this large em data
set that every time we pick a particular
cell type we see
some very specific patterns of
connectivity but the other important
rule is to link
that pattern of connectivity and that
cell
that cell classification that emerges
from the connectivity
to the to the transcriptomics to the
transcriptomics uh
classifications that that exist because
you know the
the the connectivity is basically the
structure configuration of the circuit
but the transfer atomic carries
kind of the the genes carry the
instructions about to build this
connectivity and
and one step that we think it's easier
to do
first is through the morphology of the
neurons like i mentioned in my talk
using for example pepsi
but but i'm pretty sure that in the
future will be
many other techniques that will allow us
to go even more deep into this into this
into this relationship
great um thanks thanks very much um
our our next question is is is back to
jeff um
sort of a short question with uh with
perhaps a big answer
which is what do we do with the
connectome once we have it
ah that is a
a good question um my
my initial reaction would be like what
couldn't you do with a connectome once
you had it
i think we can get some sense of of what
connectomes
are by thinking about data like genomes
what would you do with the human genome
once you had it
and you realize that a data set is not
the answer to a question
it's the dictionary or encyclopedia you
would use
to answer anyone of an infinite number
of questions
and so i think the the hope is that if
one had a whole
animal connect home there are an
uncountable number of different kinds of
questions one can ask
uh ones such as what
what do the projections where do the
protections to a particular part of the
brain come from
which particular cells are they making
synapses on
and what do those cells do with that
information where do they send it to
other parts of the brain
so one would be able to map out the
pathways between brain areas
at a synaptic level that would be
enormously valuable
but i'm what's not lost on me is that
some of the most
interesting uses of genomic information
have been on things that
i don't think anyone really imagined at
the time
and the genomes were developed for
example the origins
of humans have been
have emerged by looking at the relative
similarities of dna
of ancestral animals uh
and how humans have migrated uh across
the planet i don't think anyone thought
genomics was going to play a key role
there
but it has been transformative for that
field and i have a feeling that
connectomics would have the same kind of
opportunity
that there are questions that we can't
yet pose because the data doesn't exist
but once we have connectomes my
suspicion is there will be
a huge number of new
questions asked and new answers that the
organizers of generating this kind of
data could not have imagined at the time
they made the data
available thanks
uh thanks jeff so um kristen
a specific question for your talk how
close can the actuator get
back to its original position for
subsequent images
how much alignment is required between
two images taken
at the same position
right so that those these are all
questions that we are
um continuously experimenting with on
our in our new technology
but the short serve generalized answer
right now is that centering the region
of interest is routinely within two
micrometers on the xy
stage at a 45 degree stage tilt
any changes of course in working
distance seem to be much less
than that the beauty of this orientation
is that we only have to create one
dynamic focal plane
as opposed to if you do tilt tomography
as opposed to
one tilt and and a cone around that tilt
so that really saves us a lot and when
we go from
section to section you remember we're
going to be having 350
nanometers or 300 nanometer section
thickness so then we want to connect
the next 300 nanometer section thickness
it's the same level it's the same
alignment tool that you use for cereal
sections because they are cereal
sections they're just thicker so it's
very simple
in fact it's very simple to align the
two adjacent
virtual sections between two serial
sections that are that thick
in fact it's going to be simpler because
as people
don't often recognize each section that
you take with a diamond knife
loses on the order of seven nanometers
of section thickness
but and so with a 45 nanometer section
thickness you're losing a much greater
fraction of the section you don't really
lose any objects at seven nanometers you
can follow them easily across that
but the fraction of the overall section
that's lost at
the knife edge is much less for these
virtual sections
computed from a 300 nanometer section
thickness then versus
a 45 nanometer so i think overall we're
going to find
that alignment and reproducibility
of the location is going to be
the least of our problems the the most
the problems are going to be the same as
everybody else
figuring out how to collect and store
the
a large amount of data in a routine
fashion
and i think that's something that's
rapidly being
resolved by our two leaders here and
many of the others in this group thanks
okay so we're running a little tight on
time there's still a lot of great
questions that we'd like to get to
um but we we in this particular forum
um but we want to just quickly thank our
panel and
the audience for the great questions
this is an exciting and growing research
space there
uh there's still a lot of questions and
ideas to discuss and we will have
a forum in uh the networking lounge at 2
30
p.m it's the chat session for
connectomix so we
all invite you to join us there and
continue this discussion
and to continue with uh
with questions and sharing of ideas and
again thank you everyone
for joining
you